then we walk this way
and then we went boo all I know is
Judy Greer and I were living that day we
were living
and Mark Ruffalo was in Hell come here
no no no no no no no no no
way he hated it so much Jennifer Garner
revealing Mark Ruffalo was not 30 and
on the set of their 2004 film 13 Going
on 30 because of the now iconic Thriller
scene
[Applause]
I couldn't have had more fun while it
was fun for Jen seems it wasn't for Mark
when it came to shooting the popular
dance sequence Mark Ruffalo was in hell
yeah the actress tells Allure Mark was
almost not the Maddie to her Jenna he
wanted to quit the movie when we had our
first rehearsal he hated it so much he
so badly didn't want to do it and was
fully what am I doing with my life
that's what learning the Thriller dance
did for him and Judy and I were just
like yes
you bring it of course Mark worked
through it and learned the moves the
scene no doubt has a special place in
film dance history
[Music]
[Applause]
we just smiled every day that's that's
the biggest thing when I watched this
movie I find myself smiling when I watch
it I can't believe how much I smiled
when I made it and
the the dance sequences were a blast
they reminded me of shooting a fight
except that we were allowed to smile
instead of having to grunt
despite the tough time Mark had the
actor told E.T many years later just how
special it was working with Jennifer I
said the sweetest time we know we were
both well she was she was a big star but
I was kind of just starting out and uh
and and she was just so lovely and we
were making this really sweet movie that
had a great message for for young girls
and we were all sort of like
coming into our own at that moment and
we really loved that story and um
and Jen was just transformed into a 13
year old girl it was really amazing you
wanna know a secret
yeah
yeah you're the sweetest guy I've ever
known
[Music]